(gentle music)
(keyboard tapping)
- [Narrator] Caution: A memorandum
of a telephone conversation
is not a verbatim
transcript of a discussion.
The text in this document
records the notes
and recollections of
Situation Room Duty officers
and NSC policy staff assigned
to listen and memorialize
the conversation in written form.
- [Narrator] The United States has been
very, very good to Ukraine.
I wouldn't say that it's
reciprocal necessarily
because things are
happening that are not good,
but the United States has been
very, very good to Ukraine.
- [Narrator] Yes, you
are absolutely right,
not only 100%, but actually 1,000%
and I can tell you the following;
I did talk to Angela Merkel
and I did meet with her.
I also met and talked with Macron
and I told them that they
are not doing quite as much
as they need to be doing on
the issues with the sanctions.
They are not enforcing the sanctions.
They are not working as much
as they should work for Ukraine.
It turns out that even though logically,
the European Union should
be our biggest partner,
but technically the United States
is a much bigger partner
than the European Union
and I'm very grateful to you for that
because the United States is
doing quite a lot for Ukraine.
Much more than the European Union,
especially when we are
talking about sanctions
against the Russian Federation.
(gentle music)
- [Narrator] I would like
you to do us a favor though
because our country has been through a lot
and Ukraine knows a lot about it.
I would like you to find out what happened
with this whole situation with Ukraine,
they say Crowdstrike.
I guess you have one
of your wealthy people.
The server, they say Ukraine has it.
There are a lot of things that
went on, the whole situation.
I think you're surrounding yourself
with some of the same people.
I would like to have the
attorney general call you
or your people and I would like you
to get to the bottom of it.
As you saw yesterday, that whole nonsense
ended with a very poor performance
by a man named Robert Mueller,
an incompetent performance,
but they say a lot of
it started with Ukraine.
Whatever you can do, it's
very important that you do it
if that's possible.
- [Narrator] Yes, it is
very important for me
and everything that you
just mentioned earlier.
For me, as a president,
it is very important
and we are open for
any future cooperation.
We are ready to open a
new page on cooperation
in relations between the
United States and Ukraine.
For that purpose, I just
recalled our ambassador
from United States and he will be replaced
by a very competent and
very experienced ambassador
who will work hard on making sure
that our two nations are getting closer.
I would also like and hope
to see him having your trust
and your confidence and have
personal relations with you
so we can cooperate even more so.
I will personally tell you
that one of my assistants
spoke with Mr. Giuliani just recently
and we are hoping very
much that Mr. Giuliani
will be able to travel to Ukraine
and we will meet once he comes to Ukraine.
(gentle music)
- [Narrator] Good because I
heard you had a prosecutor
who was very good and he was shut down
and that's really unfair.
A lot of people are talking about that,
the way they shut your
very good prosecutor down
and you had some very bad people involved.
Mr. Giuliani is a highly respected man.
He was the mayor of New
York City, a great mayor,
and I would like him to call you.
I will ask him to call you
along with the attorney general.
Rudy very much knows what's happening
and he is a very capable guy.
If you could speak to
him, that would be great.
The former ambassador from
the United States, the woman,
was bad news and the
people she was dealing with
in the Ukraine were bad news,
so I just want to let you know that.
The other thing, there's a
lot of talk about Biden's son,
that Biden stopped the prosecution
and a lot of people want
to find out about that,
so whatever you can do
with the attorney general would be great.
Biden went around bragging that
he stopped the prosecution,
so if you can look into it,
it sounds horrible to me.
- [Narrator] I wanted to tell
you about the prosecutor.
First of all, I understand
and I'm knowledgeable about the situation.
Since we have won the absolute
majority in our parliament,
the next prosecutor general
will be 100% my person,
my candidate, who will be
approved by the parliament
and will start as a new
prosecutor in September.
He or she will look into the situation,
specifically to the company
that you mentioned in this issue.
The issue of the investigation of the case
is actually the issue of making
sure to restore the honesty,
so we will take care of that
and will work on the
investigation of the case.
On top of that, I would kindly ask you
if you have any additional information
that you can provide to us.
It would be very helpful
for the investigation
to make sure that we administer
justice in our country
with regard to the ambassador
to the United States from Ukraine,
as far as I recall,
her name was Ivanovich.
(gentle music)
- [Narrator] I will have
Mr. Giuliani give you a call
and I am also going to have
Attorney General Barr call
and we will get to the bottom of it.
I'm sure you will figure it out.
(gentle music)
- [Narrator] I would like
to tell you that I also have
quite a few Ukrainian friends
that live in the United States.
Actually, last time I
traveled to the United States,
I stayed in New York near Central Park
and I stayed at the Trump Tower.
I will talk to them
and I hope to see them
again in the future.
I also wanted to thank you
for your invitation to
visit the United States,
specifically Washington, DC.
On the other hand, I
also want to ensure you
that we will be very
serious about the case
and will work on the investigation.